a graphic here today because it's been a
while since we've had a graphic so i
wanted to deliver on that um
so as you all know we announced our
first tranche of sanctions
in less less than a day
after uh the beginning of the invasion
with allies and partners from the
european union the united kingdom canada
japan and australia and what we wanted
to provide to all of you today is an
overview of what we're seeing uh as an
impact on the russian economy obviously
the bite of these sanctions has not
taken place yet so this is largely in
anticipation
so let me just go through a couple of
these points
borrowing costs for the russian
government has spiked to almost 11
percent highest since 2015 foreign
investors are fleeing russia the ruble
is trading at its weakest level since
november 2020 one of the weakest
currencies in the world in response to
inflation risk the russian central bank
has hiked rates eight times in the past
year to 9.5 percent uh and bloomberg
reported just gonna cite bloomberg there
uh that the fortunes of russia's super
rich have tumbled 32 billion dollars
this year with the escalating conflict
in ukraine poised to make that wealth
destruction much larger so as i started
off saying this is before the bite even
takes place and this is just after the
beginning i mean we've only had
obviously a first tranche here
but it's this is a vicious feedback loop
that will get more severe if putin
doesn't escalate so as he's looking at
the impact on his own economy on his
rich and wealthy oligarch friends and on
the people of russia
these are the facts
regardless of what you're hearing from
the kremlin about the impact also just
wanted to note because i know that we
put out these sanctions when a lot was
happening yesterday just wanted to give
you a little bit more detail of them
obviously you hopefully have seen
the announcement in the statement from
the president about nordstrom 2. uh we
can come back to that uh but that is an
additional step today and also on banks
and the announcement we made yesterday
what we did was we um used our most
powerful sanctions tool to target two
major state-owned russian banks for the
first time that is the significance
these banks can no longer what it means
is they can no longer make any
transactions with the united states or
europe and their assets in the financial
system will be frozen they are the
glorified piggy banks some of the
glorified piggy banks for the kremlin
including one of them which is a key
financial institution where
where support military
finances has been held
and this will have a significant impact
on russian leadership in the inner
circle because their state-owned
controlled banks controlled by them i we
also were clear yesterday but again
there's a lot going on so i just wanted
to touch on this on this lightly that no
financial institution is safe and the
authority that was announced yesterday
means that we can expand this to other
financial institutions
in russia and we have every capability
and capacity to do that second we made
an announcement about
sovereign debt and essentially this
means i know there's been a lot of some
commentary out there some from russia of
course um that they have a rainy day
fund a rainy day fund is limited a rainy
day funds mean you can only tap into it
until the rainy day fund is done uh the
ability to um to purchase sovereign debt
means that you can gain access to
additional funding and what we are
essentially doing is cutting off uh
their ability to uh to tap into that
from the united states and europe
finally on elites what is significant
about this and somebody asked me this
question about what's different so some
of the people who were sanctioned
yesterday are repeat people that we have
sanctioned in the past but the
additional step we took was that we
sanctioned family members because what
we've seen in terms of tactics that
they've used in the past is they have
moved they're very sophisticated some of
these oligarchs no surprise they've
moved money around to children to family
members so they could still have access
to it and we wanted to reduce the
likelihood of that so that is an
additional step we took so just wanted
to cover that one other note today also
marks 100 days since the president
signed the bipartisan infrastructure law
time flies it's also day 400 of the
administration in the past 100 days
we've hit the ground running rolling out
nearly 100 billion dollars worth of
programs and funding to state and local
governments this funding will help
rebuild crumbling roads and bridges
replace lead pipes help provide
high-speed internet to every family in
america and produce concrete results
that change people's lives for the
better to continue this momentum today
the department of transportation
announced nearly 450 million dollars
available to strengthen port
infrastructure and supply chain
resiliency and obviously there is more
to come chris your first day in the ap
seat welcome to the front of the room no
pressure
uh so a few questions about ukraine uh
first talk about the impact of the
economy on russia uh ukraine is also
feeling a lot of economic pain right now
uh what more is the white house prepared
to do to shore up their economies rising
with financial assistance
well we have provided them uh an
extensive amount of financial assistance
including uh recently announcing one
billion dollars in sovereign i mean in
loan guarantees um and that is something
we are open to building upon and we are
going to continue to assess what the
impact is on the ukrainian economy what
is needed on the ground that applies to
both uh
access to uh to uh to
you know economic assistance as well as
humanitarian assistance so i don't have
anything to announce today uh but we
will continue to be a large provider and
supporter of uh financial and economic
assistance to ukraine uh a new ap poll
found that only 26 of americans want us
to play a major role in this in this
crisis given that this could increase
costs in americans gas prices other
economic ripples has the white house
done enough to prepare americans for
what the u.s will be and what impact it
could be on their lives well this is
very important to the president
personally it's why he gave remarks
delivered the remarks he did last week
and why he has spoken several times to
provide updates to the american people
over the last couple of days
two pieces i would note that i think are
very important as americans are tuning
in and learning more about
this con this potential conflict there's
conflict that's underway i guess i
should say between russia and ukraine
one the president has no intention of
sending
u.s military or u.s troops to fight in
ukraine
it is hard to know because i don't think
it was in your poll how people assess
what major involvement means but that
has not changed in terms of the
president's view and his approach
second is he is going to do everything
he can to reduce the impact on energy
costs for the american people and that
means engaging closely with partners
around the world it means considering a
range of options that are all on the
table
to reduce the market the impact on the
oil markets and that that is what would
impact energy costs but the last thing i
would say is that the president in the
white house you know we make national
security decisions based on what's best
for our country's national security not
on the latest polling and if you step
back what hopefully the american people
will see and have seen is that while
russia has sought to divide our allies
and the american people the president
has sought to revitalize our
partnerships and alliances and unite our
country he's standing up for our
national security interests and bedrock
democratic values against the aggression
of a dictator threatening to further
invade a sovereign country that's why
he's doing what he's doing so we're less
focused on the politics of ukraine and
more focused on preventing a war
like i have was yesterday the
administration said the goal of the
sanctions is to prevent and deter a
wider invasion of the state if russia
does attack as usual warning that
they're imminently prepared to do does
that mean that strategy has failed well
i would say as we look at it we're
focused on accomplishing two things one
is uh implementing serious costs for the
actions that have already been taken so
the actions in the dom boss and we've
taken steps beyond what we did in 2014
which obviously i just outlined at the
beginning of the briefing second yes
deterrence is part of our objective if
he goes further we will go further we
have a range of tools at our disposal i
mentioned some of the uh potential
financial steps or steps we could take
that could impact financial institutions
uh that is uh is very significant and
could have a very significant
impact but we have far more options
beyond that including export controls
and what export control steps would mean
you know russia as president putin looks
to the future of russia there is a lot
of access to different industries
technologies that he needs and would
rely on in order for the economy to grow
and flourish in the future whether it's
ai whether it's other technological
sectors biotech semiconductors a term
we've used a lot in here and what this
would do would essentially cut off
access to that that would also be a
significant step so point is we have
more steps we can take and we're going
to continue to apply those if he
escalates well i think given the
possibility of an attack seems
particularly high today can you walk us
through how the president is spending
his day how his security team is
spending the day if they're doing
anything if he's in these what could be
these final hours before an attack if
that's the case well i've seen the
reporting on this but let me let me be
very clear uh we have been saying for
days that russian military forces are in
an attack position that has not changed
they are capable of operationalizing at
any point in time we are in constant
contact with the ukrainians about their
positioning about their capacity and
capabilities we're not predicting a day
a moment or an hour that has been our
assessment and that what we've been
communicating uh with the ukrainians for
some time now let me tell you though
something else that we're also seeing or
assessing right now uh we believe
obviously we've laid out a game plan
that
we believe that president putin has been
implementing over the course of the last
several weeks if not longer it's clear
and what our assessment is is that
president putin did not expect the
united states to have the level of
information that we have did not expect
us to put out this amount of information
that we have put out did not expect the
global community to be as unified
including in the how unified the global
community was in putting out the
sanctions yesterday and what we're
seeing now our assessment is that he is
improvising adapting um and we're having
to respond and adapt his own actions to
as we are even as we are responding to
him so we don't have a new assessment i
will tell you that what the president is
doing is what he has been doing for
several days now which is continuing to
meet and engage with his national
security team obviously he had a pdb
this morning and he will receive regular
updates from his team he will continue
to engage
engage closely with partners and allies
some things that he something that he
has been doing for several days now but
that is
a continuation of what our engagement
has been given that we could be looking
at an imminent attack is there anything
this white house this president believes
he can do to stop it
well i i think
what i think what's important to note
here is we have been saying imminent for
days now and what what i'm conveying to
you is that we're also seeing
adjustments by president putin or the
need to adapt in response to what our
actions and what our response has been
so what the president has been doing has
cont has been continuing to uh to work
with partners and allies to ensure we
remain united uh to uh to leave the door
open to diplomacy but to make very clear
uh to president putin and to our
partners around the world that there
will be significant consequences beyond
what we have done already should he
invade further
uh jen what's the next trigger point for
new sanctions obviously yesterday's was
the start of the invasion what does
putin have to do next to see another way
i'm i'm not going to give you a detailed
if he does this we will do that i would
only just reiterate what i said a little
bit earlier which is that we have the
specific authority uh based on the
announcement you made yesterday to take
additional steps as it relates to
financial institutions uh in russia
there's additional
enormous financial institutions the two
largest banks for example which were not
a part of the announcement we made
yesterday there's an additional steps
we've expressed an openness to including
taking steps that relates to export
controls so this these are assessments
we will continue to make internally uh
and we have a range of tools that we are
prepared to uh steps we are prepared to
take shitty further escalate on monday
when
president putin made clear that he was
sending troops into those two breakaway
regions the white house initially said
that does not constitute an invasion
because russia already has troops there
this is just more overt the next day
president biden came out and said this
is the start of invasion what happened
overnight what changed to lead to that
change in rhetoric well i talked about
this a little bit yesterday but uh what
we looked at and what we assessed were a
range of steps i'm not obviously going
to get into military assessments or
movements today just like i didn't
yesterday um but we looked at a couple
of steps uh including uh president putin
taking steps as it relates to the douma
to ask for authority to take additional
military action beyond
that region we looked at his his
recognition we looked at the position
positioning of troops and military and
we looked at the range of steps over
that period of time to assess and make
that decision i would also note that our
deputy national security advisor was on
tv conveying that that morning as well
all right let's just just lastly on this
um the president of russia president
putin said on monday
that he felt he felt the west was going
to impose sanctions basically regardless
of what they did
given that you're obviously trying and
effectively putting a lot of pain on the
russian economy do you think these
sanctions will actually be a deterrent
well i think that is a decision for
president putin to make i mean there are
statements he has conveyed in terms of
what he wants to achieve here right the
division of nato the opposite is
happening right he wanted uh to see
nordstrom 2 move forward a key prize for
him that is obviously not happening he
wants to have a flourishing economy for
the russian people uh just even without
the bite of our sanctions that is
clearly not happening so this is an
assessment he's going to have to make
and we expect he'll hear uh from people
around him who are being impacted and
other people in russia about the impact
of these sanctions
does the white house share the
assessment of the australian prime
minister today that an attack is likely
within 24 hours
i'm not going to give an additional
timeline to it we have been saying it
could happen at any time and they are in
attack position for some time now but
i'm not going to give you an additional
day hour moment just to follow up on
that you have been saying that it's
imminent for some time you guys stopped
for a little bit then you went back to
it has there been a new warning to the
ukrainians in the last 24 hours or so
because it seems that cnn and others are
reporting that they have shared new
intelligence about the threat of just
how quickly an attack could happen we
don't know what that's based on uh we
have been conveying in close touch with
the ukrainians we have been conveying
that they are capable of
operationalizing at any time that has
been the case i'd also note that
obviously our preference would be that
president putin doesn't further invade
and as i said a few minutes ago what
we're also assessing is that he has had
to adjust adapt uh to the strength of
the unity of the global community to
what our reaction has been uh and he has
been forced to need to respond and adapt
his own actions we will see we still
very much anticipate and predict that he
will invade further
but again we're also seeing an impact on
how he's behaving and on nordstrom 2
last month the white house opposed an
effort on capitol hill to put sanctions
on this pipeline last year of course
president biden waved the sanctions on
that and now today he is imposing the
sanctions on it which is a pretty big
ship so can you just explain
the changes and we don't wear well we
don't see it as a ship at all we've
never supported the pipeline it was 90
percent built when the president took
office uh we've always spoken out
against the pipeline the question was
what was the most effective step in
order to uh to have the result that we
have now over the last 24 hours and
there were calls by some in congress to
do preemptive sanctions on or earlier
sanctions uh or take earlier steps i
should say on nordstrom 2 we disagreed
with that strategy we worked through a
diplomatic path with the germans you saw
the german chancellor make the
announcement yesterday and the
announcement today was complementary to
that so the change is just because you
were waiting on the germans to take the
first step here well actually it was
that we felt a diplomatic approach would
be the most effective approach and we
have succeeded in our efforts and we
didn't think the alternative approach
was the right one my last question a
french official recently told the wall
street journal that during his last
visit the french president found putin
was more rigid isolated and had
basically gone into a sort of
ideological and security-minded drift
the president recently spent about an
hour on the phone with him obviously he
knows putin
pretty well i wonder if he has seen a
change in the russian leader i don't
have any personal observations by
president biden about president putin to
read out but i think we all watched
including the president of the speech or
reddit uh from the other night and saw a
leader who was uh outlining a case for
war to his public
one that was based on revisionist
history
and whether that's based on isolation or
not we'll leave that to others uh to
assess
thank you jen you've said many times
today that you that there is not a new
assessment but yesterday the president
clearly chose his words carefully when
he said the world was watching the start
of an invasion which is very different
from the u.s warning today
that a full-scale russian invasion is
imminent so are you saying that nothing
has changed between
when we heard from the president
yesterday and today
i'm saying
and we've been saying for days uh that
there has been uh that they are prepared
to launch a full-scale invasion we saw
the beginning of that yesterday
so nothing has changed in that
assessment what about the figure of 80
of russian troops are now in the forward
attack position was that also the case
yesterday i don't i'm not going to be in
a position to give you move troop
assessments or movements but as i as i
said just a few minutes ago we they are
in a attack position uh that remains the
case and then to follow up on something
i asked elite yesterday
he said that the administration would
not give a time frame for when americans
might feel the impact of this conflict
why not i mean the president has said we
need to be honest about the cost of
fighting for democracy
can you share anything about a time
frame a range should people be saving
money well i think there's been a little
confusion about this because one the
announce the sanctions that we announced
yesterday will not have an impact on the
american people they will have an impact
on uh the russian elite on financial
institutions on individuals who are
trying to use those institutions to
engage uh in with uh with western banks
including president putin and his inner
circle what we're seeing in the markets
is an anticipation of a further invasion
by
president putin and what we're trying to
do and focus on is take every step we
can working around the world with our
counterparts and partners to minimize
the impact on the global
energy market so that's what we're
working on we're working on to
minimizing that but there is not an
impact from the sanctions we've
announced on the american public it
really depends in part on what president
putin does in many regards finally is
one of those options um looking at
releasing more oil from the strategic
petroleum reserve that is certainly an
option on the table
following up on luigi's question a lot
of focus on the economic pain
in russia potentially from these
sanctions but what about the economic
pain here
the russians are saying they think
gas prices in europe are going to double
how high did they get here
well i think again peter as i said to
ouija i mean some of this depends on
what president putin does so as he is
suggesting what the impact will be
around the world it's all based on what
his actions are just to be very clear
about it what the president is focused
on and is working on is taking every
step we can to
to communicate with coordinate with
engage with uh big global suppliers
around the world to minimize the impact
on the energy markets but even without
all this going on gas in california is
almost five dollars a gallon should
people across the country expect to see
that kind of a number when they go to
gas up their car five dollars six
dollars well again i think as you heard
the president say last week uh standing
up for our values is not without cost
what we're trying to do is minimize that
cost so i don't have a prediction of it
right now because we're trying to
minimize the impact on the global energy
markets okay something that you said uh
two different things that you've said so
far today he said you think right now
putin is improvising and adapting
but you've also said that you very much
anticipate and predict that he's going
to invade further so which is it is he
adapting or is he still invading think
big here peter he can still be preparing
to invade which we've said and that
continues to be the case while making
adaptations on when if how to what his
strategy is that's what we're seeing
both are true but so if that's what
you're seeing he announced sanctions
yesterday
did any russian military units turn
around and head back towards russia
again i'm not going to get into
assessments from here of movements of
any military but also what we're trying
to do is prevent a war prevent
devastation on the ukrainian people and
we're already seeing the impact on the
economy in russia we're going to
continue to make clear that there are
much uh that is if he continues to
escalate we will as well and as we wait
to see
if or how russia might retaliate against
the u.s the fbi is reportedly warning
businesses about cyber security risks
so why did you say there is no current
threat
as it relates to cyborg here there is no
current threat as it relates to cyber
here the fbi and all of the agencies in
the government uh always
provide regular updates on what
businesses and entities should do to
prepare for the potential for there is
still no immediate specific threat but
on friday the deputy national security
adviser for cyber came in here to say we
don't have the level of cyber resilience
that we wish why would somebody come to
the white house briefing room and talk
about that if there is no threat
because we anticipate that there could
be continuing threats in the future and
what we need private sector companies to
do is harden their cyber security
capabilities now now is the time to do
it okay and then finally the state
department spokesman today said you guys
are doing everything you reasonably can
to prevent human rights abuses
atrocities and potential war crimes
in
ukraine
how can you say that if all you're
announcing announcing is financial
punishment that isn't all we're
announcing we have provided a range of
assistance to ukraine humanitarian
assistance security assistance the most
of any year in history we will continue
to build on all of this assistance we
are plussing up support for our partners
and allies in the region to ensure they
know we have our back their backs and we
are abiding by our nato obligations and
we continue to also provide i think what
he was referring to is a range of public
information as well to make clear what
the intentions uh are of the russians uh
to call them out for the type of actions
we could see them taking in the future
go ahead jennifer i can ask you about
nordstrom 2 for a little better
understanding of this right now can you
say we've seen the sanctions can you say
declaratively that this pipeline
will never be operational this is
effectively dead
well we not only did the chancellor of
germany announced it's not moving
forward we also announced additional
sanctions today and it is not moving
forward right now no would you say but
just for clarity you say it's not moving
forward right now but there have been
some concern among some critics that
though he did announce the suspension
then at a later date that chancellor
schultz could say yes we are going to
begin the process again so when you say
right now that means right now that
doesn't mean for perpetuity currently
dead at the bottom of the sea peter i'm
not going to get it ahead of where we
are in the process it is not happening
it's not moving forward it hasn't been
operational for some time
uh so that is where it stands and this
is all the result of
diplomatic engagement and leadership by
the president and his engagement with
chancellor schultz let me ask you about
some other security issues as best
you're able to detail there's some
things you can't discuss so without
detailing specifics that you can't
discuss what role is the u.s playing in
securing president zelinski's safety and
does the u.s bear some responsibility in
making sure that he is safe
i'm not going to detail our
conversations or engagements about
security with the president of ukraine
who remains in kiev and is continuing to
lead the country we bear some
responsibility though for making sure
without detailing what you're doing do
we bear some responsibility for making
sure that he is safe we are going to
continue to engage with him privately
i'm not going to detail or speak to it
further from this just a last quick
question is there any circumstance
obviously we're focusing so much on
ukraine as evidenced by these questions
is there any circumstance in which the
president would hold his announcement of
the supreme court pick
after february
declaratively it'll happen it'll happen
before that has you made a decision yet
i don't have any updates on that go
ahead
um so this has been asked a few
different times but just to clarify um
you and other officials have said that
the purpose of withholding additional
and harsher sanctions is uh so that they
have a deterrent effect yeah but at the
same time you're saying that an a
broader invasion is likely so how are
both of those true
if the idea is that they would have a
deterrent effect well we're trying to
prevent that from happening and we are
making very clear
how impactful and serious what we're
considering in terms of additional
sanctions could be
and are um is inflation playing a role
at all and in deciding um you know what
what gets sanctioned what how you're
thinking about the sanctions package
inflation in the united states i assume
you're referring to
look i think we look at a range of
factors and i'll use the energy markets
as an example because i know that was a
question that was asked yesterday it's a
good one um you know as we look at what
sectors we're going to to sanction
one of the factors we look at is what
can have the biggest impact of course on
russian leadership people around
president putin on the russian economy
what we're trying to minimize is what
impact there's going to be on the united
states and global markets in a lot of
ways and if you look at energy uh the
set energy sector as an example uh
sanctioning them further could also mean
that president putin and people around
him get richer so we look at a range of
factors and certainly the impact on the
global economy is a factor as we
consider options
good if russia does launch a full-scale
invasion of ukraine should we expect to
hear from the president as we have in
the last few days i would expect you
would yes he would address the nation in
some televised fashion i would expect
you to hear from the president as you
have and then can you explain a little
bit more for uh people who are
trying to follow this continuing
situation with russian ukraine why would
the us not directly sanction putin at
this time it remains an option on the
table what i would say to people who are
trying to understand why is that
sanctions are designed to
we've always designed them to increase
the escalatory that would be an
escalatory step as would be
sanctioning the largest banks the very
largest banks
and additional components of the
financial sector as would uh taking
export control steps be so there's a
range of escalatory steps we have as
options good
um you mentioned the sanctions on all
guards from top and the president was a
little
unclear in his wording yesterday he said
that um sanctions on russian elites
wouldn't start until today that was
crossed out in the transcript to
yesterday the reason i'm asking is
that's part of this sort of first track
of sanctions are we going to see more
elites sanctioned or would that only
happen if
russia takes additional escalatory steps
um i can check if there are additional
ones i'm not tracking additional ones
that were holding for a roll out i will
note on your first part of your question
that uh for the elite individuals if
they were to have used their fine their
bank card i guess uh to make a financial
transaction it wouldn't have been
working yesterday
um
there was a cyber attack on ukrainian uh
government websites today i know the nfc
has already said that it was sort of
similar to the one that we saw on
ukrainian banks earlier and would be in
keeping with what you expect from russia
but i'm wondering if at this point
you've made a
definitive determination that russia was
responsible if so if you have any sort
of retaliation or response to yeah we
have not well we have not attributed
today's activity yet that would be very
fast even fast for us as fast as last
week was we do consider it as i think
some of my nsc colleagues said to be
consistent with the type of activity
russia would carry out in a bid to
destabilize ukraine it's consistent with
what we saw
last week we attributed similar
incidents to the russian government and
we of course consider these further
incidents to be consistent with the type
of activity we've seen russia take over
the course of time we are in
conversation with
ukraine regarding the cyber related uh
needs including as recently as today and
we're going to move with urgency to
assess uh the nature and extent of this
what steps needs to be take taken and
therefore our response then the
president's got a
meeting a virtual meeting with the g7
tomorrow morning yeah obviously i think
the topic is going to be ukraine but
yeah
i was wondering if you could put any
meat on the bottom of
what the president's trying to
what his objective is and that and that
he's looking to accomplish well uh
one of the steps the president has been
focused on is ensuring that we are
coordinated with key allies and partners
around the world and certainly the g7 is
an important entity to remain very
closely engaged with the g7 is 50
of the world's economy and joined us all
of them in this first tranche of
sanctions announced yesterday uh the
president is a believer that this level
of coordination happens by accident it
happens through a lot of work and in
close engagement we're obviously at a
pivotal point uh in this in this process
and so he felt tomorrow was the time to
discuss with them what we're seeing what
it looks like what's next and engage uh
in this format
um so a couple questions on this first
trash of sanctions
have what's going to be announced in
that first batch been announced for when
we see more of things today the first
challenge has been announced uh and
obviously the nordstream 2 announcement
today is an additional part of that i
can certainly check if there's anything
additional coming at this point be on
for the first tranche not that i am
aware of but i will check and make sure
that's correct and then um when you all
talk about this first tranche of
sanctions um can you give us a sense of
like how many
tragedies if that's right where are in
this toolbox you have to to apply i mean
how many sets of stations are we talking
about i understand the question it's
hard for me to give that assessment it
really depends on what escalatory
actions uh president putin takes if he
goes further we will go further what
that looks like i can't outline for you
at this point in time i gave you the
sense a little bit of what some
additional options are right export
controls uh sanctioning additional
financial institutions larger financial
institutions those are all on the table
as are other options but in terms of
what the breakdown of tranches would
look like i can't outline that from you
for you at this point from here in terms
of this cyber attack um we just were
asked about does will the u.s or could
we expect the u.s to have some sort of
retaliatory behavior towards russia in
response to this we always reserve that
option and obviously we haven't uh made
an attribution for this recent recent uh
ddos attack um as we go through the
process of doing that we'll certainly
consider what uh actions could be taken
as well one final question um actually
on the jcpoa sure there have been
reports that the u.s iran is reaching
closing in on some sort of deal would
you all confirm that that is an accurate
assessment that you are inching towards
a potential deal this week well what
we're seeing is there is significant
progress uh being made and we are close
to a possible deal uh but there are a
number of very difficult issues that
remain unresolved and uh there's very
little time remaining to reach a deal
given the pace of iran's nuclear
advances also i would note that
typically the most difficult components
the last mile is where it where there is
the most difficult conversations in
negotiations so yes significant progress
and we are close but there's a lot that
still needs to be worked out uh it is
true that iran
we believe if iran shows seriousness we
can and should reach an understanding on
mutual return to full implementation of
the jcpoa within potentially within days
but there is still more work that needs
to be done so you all are optimistic or
i mean that's mixed we are we are
encouraged by the significant progress
but having been through a few of these i
would note that often the most difficult
negotiations happen in the in the last
portion
but
thanks jen um so
following up on the north stream just
i'm wondering if anything happened i
understand you were saying that there
was an intent to want to do this in a
coordinated way with the germans and
obviously they made their action
yesterday but was there anything else
that happened on the ground in ukraine
yesterday that warranted the sanction
happening today rather than yesterday
no it would but it's part of our first
trance of sanctions so we would see it
as a part of what was rolled out
yesterday and then you were also telling
you i think you told caitlyn that um
that you wanted this approach with
germany rather than an alternative just
looking at you know the president last
year in cincinnati the construction is
already kind of going at this point
exactly 90 of it yeah right right he was
saying so
why is this a better way more effective
way than
issuing sanctions unilaterally and then
possibly pressuring the germans to take
action themselves well it hasn't been
operational which is an important
component right it's not like oil has
been flowing through nordstream 2 which
is a very important component here and
we made the assessment others can have
different assessments that this would be
the way to achieve the outcome that
we've now achieved um others can have
different assessments there's no proof
or evidence that their approach would
have worked ours has worked
more so the question was why
why
would not issuing sanctions last year
earlier
why wouldn't have that been effective
because we felt working in coordination
uh with the our german counterparts uh
through a diplomatic process would be
the most effective way to approach it
and i'll pivot just two more uh can you
outline what exactly doug jones has been
doing in terms of the skoda's process
who he's been talking to on the hill
lastly uh the march 18th mass mandate uh
for travel just is the administration
considering extending that or is that
seen as an expiration date
um on the first i'm sure once there is a
an announcement to be made we will have
more detail about all of the engagements
that have led up to it but certainly uh
senator jones is playing an integral
role engaging with uh senators engaging
with uh
different stakeholders uh and
individuals who want to uh to to give
their view uh on uh where this should
head um i'm sure we'll have more details
once an announcement is made as it
relates to the march 18th timeline um
the cdc as in in the process of
reviewing um their mass guidelines and
their mass guidance um we will let them
make any announcements on that but i
don't have anything to predict at this
point about march 18th and the and where
that stands on planes
yeah thanks jim earlier uh during
today's briefing you said
uh it's the us's assessment that
president putin did not expect of the
u.s to have this level of information
that we have did not expect us to put
out the amount of information that we
put out and did not expect the global
community to be as unified as it is what
have you seen
from putin's actions from russia's
actions that have
led to that conclusion that assessment
well i think why i was conveying that is
because what we've seen um and i don't
think i can give much more detail than
that other than to say what we've seen
is him adjusting and adapting um some of
his actions and needing to respond to
what our actions are
and we've obviously been
making uh
assessing that he is prepared to
operationalize at any time that has not
changed uh but uh you know we are also
watching closely what he does what's
your response to the administration's
response to lawmakers from both sides of
the aisle if you say president biden
still hasn't gone far enough with
sanctions representative adams yesterday
said quote the administration must go
further uh today senator graham called
the administration's initial response
inadequate and he said let's quickly up
our game so what is the strategy behind
holding back some of these larger
sanctioned possibilities that you talked
about
well our strategy has been start high
which is certainly what we did we did
not sanction a major bank or financial
institution back in 2014 this is a
farther step than that as i noted a
little bit earlier we also sanction not
just oligarchs but also family members
around them to cut off their ability to
preserve their funding and financing and
our our approach and our strategy has
been to preserve a range of sanctions
and options that we can also uh
escalate to should we need to obviously
our preference is that president putin
de-escalates but if russia does invade
further as it uh you know there are
indications that could does that mean
that those sanctions imposed yesterday
imposed today were a failure well again
part of them were costs part of them is
an effort to prevent a war we're doing
that not alone but in coordination with
our partners and allies around the world
that is the way to do it that is the
strong way to do it that is the
effective way to do it there may be
others who have different points of view
they're welcome it's a free country they
can have those points of view
but our approach has been to date to
to respond
with strong sanctions to start high and
build from there and that is what we
will continue to do if he escalated
lastly on the supreme court nomination
process can you confirm that the
interviews are now finished
ahead of
an announcement before the end of the
month
i'm not going to confirm any details
about the process i would note that we
are five days away from the end of
february if my math is correct uh the
interviews are typically late stage in
the process um so we are getting close
to an announcement go ahead thanks jeff
i want to ask about food prices but
first a quick question about ukraine
just a short while ago separatists in
eastern ukraine formally asked president
putin for military help is that the
signal that the us expects a broader
invasion is about to begin
well i think as we've said from the
beginning
there are going to be a range of false
flag operations that we
have expected to and laid out the
playbook
to see this is an example of it that is
suggesting that they feel under threat
by whom the ukrainians that the russians
are threatening to attack so we'll
continue to call out what we see as
false flag operations or efforts to
spread disinformation about what the
actual status is on the ground
and americans they just experienced
their most expensive thanksgiving this
conflict will likely drive up food
prices grocery prices uh what does the
white house minimizing the impact of
even higher grocery prices actually look
like i don't think we've ever minimized
the higher impact of the cost of food i
wouldn't no i would not let me finish
it's actually i think the price of a
turkey just a couple of months ago was
about a dollar more if we just look back
at the facts of what was actually
happening at the time and we've talked a
bit in here about our concerns about uh
meat conglomerates jacking up the prices
if people go into the store and they try
to buy a pound or two pounds of meat
what we're seeing as the impact of not
enough competition in the industry but
the president has repeatedly expressed
concern about cost for the american
people that's one of the reasons he
continues to press for steps with
congress that will lower significant
costs on people's budgets whether it's
child care health care elder care
whatever it may be that is a central
part of his economic agenda good uh
thanks jim you've said and the president
has said several times that uh you know
to americans that the u.s is not sending
the military into ukraine uh not going
to war with russia and i just wanted to
ask given that you're warning of a
full-fledged invasion potential attacks
on kiev um how the administration is as
confident as it is that that won't
become necessary at some point that
there won't be any need down the road
for military engagement with russia that
is not a decision the president is going
to make
based on we are not going to be in a war
with russia or putting military troops
on the ground in ukraine fighting russia
so ultimately if vladimir putin takes
all of ukraine that's the situation that
the administration is
not going to condemn obviously going to
punish economically but that's not
something that will be
engaged well that is that is several
steps down the road but what i will tell
you is the president has been crystal
clear and consistent he is not sending
us troops to fighting ukraine that has
not changed has there been any
discussion on the strategy of saying
that though so publicly and potentially
giving putin an indication that the u.s
and nato allies are willing to see
that sphere of influence outside of nato
boundaries to him
again i i don't know how many more times
i can say it there's no scenario the
president is not sending us troops to
fight in ukraine against russia we are
taking a range of other steps as you've
touched on but i would say they're quite
significant not only are we the largest
provider of security assistance
humanitarian assistance and economic
assistance to ukraine but we have also
taken significant steps to plus up not
only our nato forces and our forced
posture but the forced posture of our
partners in eastern europe to make sure
they know we have their backs and
support them we will continue to plus
this all up but the president is not
sending us troops to fight in ukraine
that hasn't changed
well thank you sir this is a little bit
related to um eli's question
so it's very clear what russian
escalation could be right go from today
to
you know the whole of ukraine or
bombardier or there's a lot of things
along the way
um
you've laid out all sorts of different
sanctions that are being considered yeah
but what what is the arc
it's very clear what the russian arc
could be right you could ultimately go
to whatever you know what kind of
ukraine
what is the art of the us response like
what's
what's the equivalent to
you know smashing here to pieces
again i i'm not going to outline if this
then that from here and and i unless you
know something the rest of us don't know
i don't know that anyone knows exactly
what the next step will be as much as
we're preparing we're seeing them uh
positioning their military forces for
attack uh obviously until uh they
further invade they haven't further
invaded right if they do and take
escalatory steps we will take escalatory
steps what those look like will depend a
lot on what the actions are one other
question please uh we've got the g7
virtual meeting tomorrow the president's
made a lot of outreach to allies
obviously um is any consideration
whatsoever being given to some kind of
last-ditch outreach to the russians
either from the president or him
encouraging the europeans to
have another go at it
well i talked about this a little bit
yesterday i mean a couple days ago
obviously the president made clear are
we made clear on his behalf that if they
didn't invade uh that he was open to
have engaging with president putin and
that would follow a meeting or
engagement between our secretary of
state uh and foreign minister lavrov
obviously we're in a different point at
this point in time it doesn't feel
appropriate or the right step to to have
those diplomatic engagements right now
we will always leave the door open if
they de-escalate we will certainly
proceed with uh diplomatic engagement
but no we're not considering a meeting
with president putin or engagement with
him right now hi i have a question on
mexico but first on ukraine um on the
sanctions on north stream 80 um can you
confirm that they will only affect gas
from not the four european companies
that are shareholders of the consortium
i think we put out an extensive
statement on this um as well as some
details i can let me see if i can just
outline it all from you from here and we
can get that to you after the briefing
as well what was your other question
yeah on mexico the president of mexico
said today that the u.s isn't well
informed about violence against
journalists in mexico
and that there is an impunity for those
crimes
are you worried that he is downplaying
the risks that journalists face in that
country
well i would say first we've seen
factually the threats that have been
posed to journalists in mexico and we've
seen um the threats we've seen um and
that is a concern that i think the
secretary of state was expressing on
behalf of the united states about uh
those abuses so i think he was speaking
to facts we've seen on the ground
good job a couple domestic questions for
you first does the white house have any
reaction to the order from texas
governor abbott uh calling for
prosecutions of
parents who move forward with gender
affirming uh treatments for their kids
well i spoke a little bit unfortunately
to another law that we saw moving in
florida
just last week
and but let me reiterate some of the
points i made then
there are efforts in some states not
just texas but also florida
unfortunately others
designed to target and attack the kids
who need support the most lgbtqi plus
students who are already vulnerable to
bullying and violence just for being
themselves this isn't an isolated action
as is evidenced by multiple states
pursuing this we're seeing republican
leaders take actions to regulate what
students can or cannot read what they
can or cannot learn and most troubling
who they can or cannot be uh you've
heard the president he also i think put
out a tweet or i think or a statement uh
to the florida law and i would say we
have the same concerns about uh these
type of actions we're seeing in texas
and then in florida uh governor
desantis's administration is moving
forward with the rule uh targeting uh
shelters that house unaccompanied minors
does the biden administration have any
contingency plans for the unaccompanied
minors who may be affected by that role
in terms of their housing i think this
is an important thing to call to call
out here because what we're talking
about here is one it's our view it's our
responsibility i should say as an
administration to responsibly uh and
safely care for unaccompanied children
we're talking about minor kids here so
hhs is currently examining all legal
options available at its disposal to
ensure that our shelters continue to
provide services to the unaccompanied
miners in our care i would remind you
all that um that
there have been kids in florida uh these
facilities since 2005. i mean these
facilities have been open in
for 17 years now um
being overseen by the office of refugee
resettlement um so uh we're obviously
looking at legal options here but i also
would say this is um you know really
flies in the face of what should be a
moral uh view of anyone that taking
caring for the uh the safe care for
unaccompanied children should be a part
of what we all uh want to be active
participants and go in thanks jen
so the justice department today
announced that they are ending the trump
administration's 2018 china initiative
and replacing it with a broader uh
approach towards you know more countries
russia iran north korea i know that
justice officials have spoken about this
but if you can elaborate from this
podium the reasoning behind that and
especially in addressing the complaints
of discrimination from asian americans i
would have to dig further into this
patsy i'd really point you to the
department of justice i'm not sure we
have more to add from here and then just
on the global pandemic response can you
confirm the amount of funding that the
administration has requested from
congress we're hearing this number of
five billion dollars that activists say
it's not nearly enough to help vaccinate
the world as well as to stop new
variants from you know attacking the us
as well well i don't well i don't have
any specific numbers we're still in
conversation with the hill at this point
about funding and funding needs both
domestically and internationally we want
to continue to
be
the provider of not just vaccines but
vaccine know-how and assistance to the
global community we don't believe that
cove that the pandemic sees borders and
we know that in order to continue to get
it under control we need to be
the leader in the world on this effort
but numbers are still being discussed
with the hill so i don't have any more
specifics unfortunately quickly on on
ukraine are you at this point urging
americans to leave russia i know that i
think two days ago the embassy in moscow
is issuing an advisory saying for
americans evacuation plans that do not
rely on government assistance but are
you actually telling americans in russia
to leave the state department makes
those assessments and recommendations
and they update them regularly so i
point to them for any updates go ahead
thank you jen um a few on ukraine first
uh the kremlin has vowed counter
sanctions in response to the us we've
not seen what those will look like but
it sounds like the us has quite a bit of
intelligence so i'm wondering if you
have any view on what the nature of
those counter sanctions could be what
impact they could have on consumers and
how the administration could offset that
well we've seen those threats or those
reports but i don't have anything to
provide or assess from here yesterday
president biden said nothing in putin's
lengthy remarks indicated any interest
in pursuing real dialogue on european
security in the year 2022
if that's the case what do you see as
the end game here
well again uh our our hope is that uh
putin will decide to de-escalate uh that
he will feel uh the threat of the uh
sanctions what the impact will be on the
russian economy on the russian people on
the people who surround him uh they are
meant to have a deterrent impact that he
will feel the weight of being a pariah
in the global community it does not mean
we have never closed the door to
diplomacy and the president didn't have
that intention of conveying that
yesterday either and certainly
if it is an appropriate time he will
engage with president putin again but
now is not the appropriate time or he's
continuing to invade a sovereign country
and finally the administration is
working on putting its budget together
how much humanitarian assistance for
ukraine is the administration for care
to support it it's a good question what
we're going to and it's hard for me to
give you a number right now because
we're going to continue to assess the
needs on the on the ground and we
certainly uh are prepared for the
potential for there to be
major humanitarian continued
humanitarian needs on the ground
obviously those existed have existed
since back to 2014
but we want to continue to be the
largest provider of humanitarian
assistance this is something we will
continue to discuss with colleagues in
congress as well
all right
okay thanks everyone we'll do this again
tomorrow
[Music]
yes ma'am
sure this is this small window and then
next to this window you have a lot going
on the foreign policy we do means you
guys have a lot going on too all of us
yes right how about that um with that
said
how is the president feeling in the
midst of all this as it relates to
this impending
nomination this historic nomination that
he's getting ready to make
and tell me more about what you mean how
is he feeling how's it feel i mean he's
got all of this going on with ukraine
and russia and then he's got this
historic uh nomination of the first
black woman
to potentially sit on the u.s supreme
court yeah it's history being made in
the midst of looking at sanctions and
other things that are happening overseas
how is he feeling about this piece over
here yes i mean i think the president is
looking forward to announcing a historic
eminently qualified black woman to serve
on the supreme court uh he has feels
there's tremendous honor in that he
takes the role uh that every president
has in selecting and nominating someone
to the supreme court very seriously
that's why he has been spending time not
just studying bios
but also reviewing cases and engaging
very closely with an internal team on
this process but he is very much looking
forward to making this announcement and
getting this individual confirmed how
many nominees has he met with i'm not
going to get into further detail on that
i expect once he makes an announcement
we'll have more details to share and
lastly yeah the administration has been
fervent
and fervent i can't even get the word
out saying that they will that you all
will fight against anyone
who tries to mar or ruin the reputation
of any of these nominees yeah what are
you willing to do in this fight to keep
their reputations that they walked into
this process with
that's a good question april i think
what we mean by that is
there are a range of eminently qualified
black women whose names have been out
there as potential nominees all of these
women would make tremendous additions to
the supreme court
and we have also seen efforts to mar
their reputations and what we mean by
that is we are going to
fight back even before obviously the
president has made a decision or made an
announcement against efforts to tar any
of their reputations that means
defending them publicly standing up for
them providing information to uh to
you know debunk
any information that's being put out
about them that's inaccurate um and
hopefully uh they all feel that we have
uh we have uh delivered on that promise
but that has been pr important to the
president from the beginning thank you
thank you everyone see you tomorrow or
whatever
[Music]
you